القليل همم
مباركه خادم الحرمين الشريفين ايد الله
لاعلان الميزانيه في جلسه مجلس الوزراء
والتي راعت ااا ما تشهده المملكه ولله
الحمد من
تنامي متسارع وتحقيق ااه عديد من
المستهدفات
تحت رؤيه المملكه 2030 واستراتيجيات
ومشاريع متعدده سواء ومكانيه
واستمعنا وشاهدنا ااا قبل قليل ايضا ما
ذكر
صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
بمناسبه صدور ميزانيه
بخصوص ما يتعلق
بالانجازات التي تحققت خلال العام 20 22
وهي نتيجه لعمل دؤوب وجهد كبير جدا
تم خلال سنوات همم
سابقه بدانا نشاهد نتائجها ولله الحمد
فيما تحقق من انجازات على المستوى الماليه
العامه لعام 22
وما هو مخطط باذن الله تعالى في سنه 23
تحدث
عن عديد من الاستراتيجيات التي تم بدات
تنفيذها
وعن عديد من المستندات التي تم تحقيقها
وساذكر على سبيل المثال ااا الجزئيتين
مهمه كان سموه ولا يزال يرعاه بشكل حفيف
الاولى الاسكان
وتحقيق انجازات سابقا لوقتها فيما يتعلق
بنسبه ملكيه
المواطنين للسكن
ولله الحمد تحقق انجاز مميز بارتفاع
النسبه بدايه الرؤيه من 42% الى ان وصلنا
الى ما وصلنا الى الان ايضا مشاركه وتحدث
سمو عن اهميه الموارد ودور المواطن وهو
العنصر الاساسي
التي تعتمد عليه المملكه في ما يحدث من
تطور ومن هذا تحدث سمو ايضا عن تمكين
المراه
واستطعنا من خلال العديد من الاستراتيجيات
والمبادرات والمشاريع من الوصول الى
مستهدف كان مخطط له 20 30 تحقق بنهايه
العام الحمد وصلنا الى
35.7% من مشاركه المراه في السوق العام
امم من نسب كانت قلبي كثيره اقل من النصف
في السابق تحدث ايضا
في ذلك استراتيجيات التي اطلقت مؤخرا
الاستراتيجيه الصناعيه التي تستهدف الى
رفع مستوى
القطاع الصناعي
استغلال الممكنات التي وفرتها الحكومه
فيما يتعلق برفع مستوى الناتج المحلي
رفع مستوى مدخلات الوطنيه في المشاريع
الحكوميه والمشاريع التي ينفذها صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه والشركات التابعه له
شهيدنا انجازات واضحه جدا فيما يتعلق بسوق
العمل
من تحقيق انخفاض في نسبه البطاله الى
مستويات
للمشاهده خلال 20 سنه الماضيه
شهدنا كثير ايضا من
الانجازات فيما يتعلق بتمكين القطاع الخاص
همم تمكين المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه اعلن
مؤخرا عن انشاء بنك المنشات الصغيره
والمتوسطه وهناك العديد همم من ما تحقق
ولله الحمد يتحدث عنه صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان باسهاب في كلمه بثت
او بيان صحفي القديم
فيما يتعلق
بالارقام ولا التوقعات الاقتصاديه
ساتحدث باختصار ومن ثم ساترك المجال همم
الاسئله
ساتحدث عن النمو الاقتصادي في المدى
المتوسط ومن ثم اتحدث عن ارقام الميزانيه
وبعض المؤشرات الاساسيه
لسنه 22
والمتوقع لسنه 23
همم
في ما يتعلق
بالمؤشرات الاقتصاديه اعتقد ويمكن امامنا
في الشاشه اييه تكلم صاحب السمو الملكي
اييي عن توقعات النمو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بنهايه هذا العام من المتوقع ان
تصل الى
8.5%
وهذا الرقم يمكن يجب ان اتوقف عنده قليلا
لما تحدثنا في مثل هذا الوقت تقريبا عام
الماضي كنا نتوقع تقريبا سبعه فاصله اربعه
في المئه
وكان الكثير يتحدثون عن الحكومه متفائله
في الرقم هذا
تفاعل
ال ال المجتمع الدولي مع ما يحدث في
المملكه رفعوا توقعاتهم المملكه هي
الوحيده على مستوى دول مجموعه العشرين
التي تمر رفع التوقعاتها التوقعات المواهب
الاقتصادي من صندوق النقل الدولي مرتين
خلال العام الحالي وحتى مع ذلك وصلوا الى
7.6 ااه اعلى من توقعاتنا الاساسيه لكن لم
يصلوا الى همم فعلا تحقق على ارض الواقع
وهو ثمانيه فاصله خمسه وهو الاعلى من بين
دول مجموعه ال20
المطمئن بالنسبه لنا ايضا هو محل تركيزنا
محل تركيزنا هو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
للنشاط القطاع الخاص
وهو محور رؤيه المملكه 20 30 من تنويع
الاقتصاد
وتمكين القطاع الخاص
ما نتوقع ان ننتهي فيه هذا العام هو
تقريبا 5.9%
نمو انشطه القطاع الخاص في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي واعتقد هذا رقم مهم جدا لانه
سنشاهد خلال سنوات القادمه
خلال الاربع خمس سنوات همم الماضي الناتج
المحلي الاسمي همم لاول مره في تاريخ
المملكه يتخطى حاجز المليار- التريليون
دولار
نتوقع باذن الله ان ننتهي هذا العام
بثلاثه فاصله تسعه خمسه سبعه ترليون ريال
العام القادم
الارقام امامنا
3,869 ترليون وفي عام 24 نتوقع ان يكون
الناتج المحلي لاسمي تقريبا في حدود ثلاثه
فاصله 49
ريال باذن الله تعالى
في المدى المتوسط
واعتقد هذا
جزء من رحله
بداناها من بدايه رؤيه المملكه 2030 ان
الخطط
واضحه جدا استراتيجيات واضحه جدا وتنفيذها
من ثلاث اربع سنوات وبدا الان ياتي ثماره
نتوقع
همم الاستثمار ينمو بوتيره اسرع وشاهد
خلال العام الحالي نمو الاستثمار من
القطاع الخاص بنسبه تتجاوز ال20%
مقارنه بالعالم الماضي
بالاستراتيجيات في ذلك استراتيجيات
الاستثمار الوطنيه للاستثمار برنامج شريك
البرامج المتعلقه الصغيره والمتوس ثلاث
اتوقع ينمو مشاركه القطاع الخاص باذن الله
تعالى ايضا شاهدنا جهود كبيره جدا تبذلها
الحكومه استباقيه للتعامل مع الازمات
ولا اعتقد انه احتاج ان اؤكد على
النجاحات اللي تمت
بتفاعل كبير جدا بين الحكومه والمواطنين
والقطاع الخاص اثناء جائحه
نشاهد ايضا شيء مشابه لها تم خلال العام
هذا بتفاعل الحكومه مع التضخم العالمي
والتضخم على مستوى العالم المتوسط حسب
تقديرات صندوق النقد الدولي تقريبا 8.8
ااااه
على مستوى الاقتصاد العالمي
استطاعت الحكومه السباقيه ولو نتذكر في
العام الماضي تقريبا في منتصف العام
الماضي عندما ااا احسست المملكه وفقا
لتقديرات الاقتصاديين المميزين صراحه اللي
يعملون في الحكومه ان الاجراءات التي
اتخذها عدد من الدول في ما يتعلق بدعم
اقتصاداتها وتوفير سيوله عاليه جدا في
اقتصادات بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
اوروبا وغيرها من الدول سينتج عنها تسارع
في مستوى التضخم
اتخذت الحكومه قرار في شهر سبعه من العام
الماضي بوضع سقف على اسعار الوقود في
الاقتصاد السعودي
ولونه لاحظ ان نسبب الرئيسي للتضخم على
مستوى العالم كان اسعار الطاقه
فكبح جماح التضخم في المملكه بقرار
الحكومه من العام الماضي شاهدنا اثاره
العام الماضي وهذه السنه في مستويات تضخم
منخفضه نسبيا ومنخفضا بشكل كبير جدا عن ما
نشاهده في العالم التضخم مستويات السعوديه
بنهايه هذا العام نتوقع ان يصل الى
الاثنين فاصله سته ومن ثم ينزل للسنه
القادمه الى مستويات اقل قد تصل الى اثنين
فاصله واحد
بالمئه همم الممكنات اللي وفرتها الحكومه
ايضا
للقطاع الخاص وتكلمنا يمكن العام الماضي
عندما سالت عن
الارادات غير النفطيه همم ارتفاع التكاليف
عن القطاع الخاص همم ذكرته بشكل واضح ان
الحكومه الان تستهدف نمو الاقتصاد ونمو
الاقتصاديه يعني نمو الايرادات ولا نستهدف
فقط نمور الايرادات لوحدها
فاتخذنا مبادرات متعدده خلال العام هذا من
من ضمنها تخفيض بعد الرسوم الجمركيه من
ضمنها تخفيض
وتقسيط حتى بعض
الاعباء الماليه على القطاع الخاص ما في
ذلك المقابل المالكي كان يدفع مقدما لمده
12 شهر الان سمحنا انه يدفع على اقساط
ربعيه
وتسارعت وتيره دفع مستحقات القطاع الخاص
من قبل الحكومه بموجب النظام الحكومه لها
ان تدفع خلال 45 يوم همم من وصوله اوامر
الدفع لوزاره الماليه
صارعنا في ذلك ايضا سارعنا في متابعه
الجهات الحكوميه ورفع فعاليه الادارات
الماليه في الجهات الحكوميه لتسريع عمليات
الدفع لو لاحظ سنوات سابقه كان الربع
الرابع
في مدفوعات القطاع الخاص همم انخفض الى
يمكن تقريبا
العامل الماضي السنه هذه تقريبا في حدود
30 32%
وهذا نعتقد انه انجاز مميز للجهات
الحكوميه همم وادارتها
مطالبات ال- ال- القطاع الخاص همم
اطلقت مجموعه من الاستراتيجيات لن اتحدث
عنها لان اغطيت بشكل كبير جدا لكن ساتحدث
ويمكن تكلم سمو ولي العهد اليوم عن
الاستراتيجيه الصناعيه ونعتقد استراتيجيه
الصناعيه سيكون لها دور محوري في تمكين
القطاع الخاص ورصد لها ميزانيات مميزه
صراحه
لتمكين القطاع الخاص وتحفيز القطاع الخاص
وتوفير البنيه التحتيه وايضا من الجانب
التشريعي والتنظيمي همم تم همم تعديلات
كبيره على نظام مشتريات الحكوميه لتمكين
المحتوى المحلي
الصندوق الاستثمارات العامه اعلن عن
استهداف همم محتوى محلي 60% في المشاريع
والشركات التابعه للصندوق
الصندوق لسماره العامه ايضا
عامل حراك مميز في الاقتصاد المحلي انشا
تقريبا 60 شركه نتج عن 60 شركه هذه
ضخ كبير جدا من الطلب والدوره الاقتصاديه
في القطاع الخاص
والمهم ايضا انه تمكن من انشاء وتوفيق
تقريبا 500,000 وظيفه
للمواطنين من هذه المشاريع
فيما يتعلق بالارقام وانكسار
بيان الميزانيه واعلان مجلس الوزراء قبل
قليل
سننتهي هذه السنه باذن الله تعالى بارادات
ترليون 234
مليار ااا نفقات تريليون و132 وبالتالي
الفاعل سيكون في حدود المليار ال 200
مليار
ريال هذا العام العام القادم نتوقع
الايرادات في حدود تريليون 130
والنفقات في الحدود 114
والفائز في حدود 16 مليار اا في توقعاتنا
بشكل عام اا توقعات متحفظه وفي بيان
الميزانيه نشرنا ثلاث توقعات او
سيناريوهات للايرادات ستجدنا في بيان
الميزانيه السيناري الاساسي اللي عدنا
اليوم وسيناريو متحفظ ياخذ في الاعتبار
التطورات الاقتصاديه والتغيرات الممكن هذا
المستوى الاقتصاد العالم التي قد تؤثر على
الايرادات في المملكه
وسناريو متفائل او اكثر همم في الايرادات
ايضا في الاعتبار احتمالات تطورات ايجابيه
في الاقتصاد العالمي قد تؤدي زياده في
الارادات
جيد بس يعرج على المخصصات القطاعيه
البنود العامه 165 ااا قطاع الامن 105
مليار القطاع العسكري
259 مليار وهو مرتفع كما تلاحظون عن هذا
العام عن العام الماضي همم في قطاع
الاداره العامه 37 والموارد الاقتصاديه 72
مليار قطاع التنميه الصحه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه تقريبا 189 مليار ريال واا ال-
ال- الخدمات البلديه 63 واودوا نوضح ان
هناك انتقال بعد انتقال وزاره الاسكان دمج
في الاسكان مع البلديات انتقلت ميزانيه
الاسكان الى القطاع البلدي
قطاع التعليم 189
مليار وقطاع التجهيزات الاساسيه
والنقل
34 مليار
تفاصيل اكثر ستجدونها باذن الله تعالى في
بيان الميزانيه للنشر قبل قليل على موقع
وزاره الماليه وايضا ادعوكم الى حضور
ملتقى الميزانيه ملتقى الميزانيه سيعقد
يوم الاحد ويوم الاثنين
سيحضر فيه عدد من اصحاب السمو المعالي
سيتحدثون بالتحديد عن قطاعاتهم وما تم
انجازها خلال هذا العام وما هو المتوقع
خلال الفتره الماضيه امامنا الارقام فيما
يتعلق بالسنيرهات الايرادات
اللي تاخذ في الاعتبار التطورات
الاقتصاديه العالميه واثرها ايضا على
الاقتصاد السعودي هو الاثر المحتمل على
الارادات
في ما يتعلق ب ااا المدى المتوسط الارقام
تشاهدونا خلفي اجباري الايرادات المتوقعه
لسنه 24 تريليون و146 مقابل تريليون 205
مليار في عام 25 النفقات 24 تريليون 125
وفي عام 25 تريليون و134 وفائد الميزانيه
21 مليار في عام 24
وواحد 70 مليار في سنه 25
ايضا تفاصيل اكثر في بيان الميزانيه شكرا
لكم واتمنى لنا ولكم وللوطن ولجميع
المواطنين باذن الله تعالى سنه
مباركه تبشر بالخير انا متفائل جدا من
ماتم خلال عام 22 ومتفائل اكثر
بالمستقبل لدينا فرص كبيره جدا وتحدث سمو
ولي العهد عن المواطنين ودورهم الاساسي
انا شخصيا متفائل انا فخور جدا جدا
بما اشاهد من ابناء وبنات المملكه والجهد
الكبير الذي يبذل مشاهده على مستوى وزاره
الماليه على منظومه وزاره الماليه
والهيئات والمراكز
والمكاتب التابعه لوزاره الماليه لكن
نشاهد ايضا على مستوى
الوزارات والاجهزه الحكوميه بشكل عام شباب
وشابات يعملون على مدار الساعه لتحقيق
لديهم شغف كبير جدا نشكرهم عليه لا اتوقف
عن ذلك ان اعتقد مشاهد قفزه كبيره جدا في
القطاع الخاص
نشاهد قفزه كبيره في مجالات متعدده في
المنشات في الرواد الاعمال
رقم واحد فقط
في عام 22
في عام 22 بقدر ما كان فيه بعض الصعوبات
اللي واجهت بعض القطاعات
عدد المنشات اللي تم انشائها مقابل لانشاء
المنشات التي تم اقفالها في سنه 22 84 تم
انشاء ثمانيه اضعاف منشات جديده من رواد
اعمال خلال سنه 22 مقابل